let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
they're free divine oh yeah this'll make
a put your mother's panties on walnut
boy just that dirty baby this will make
you pour hot water on your titties come
on Stevie
[Applause]
sound slips away
sotto
so come over
wow-whee
[Music]
Wow
what a hit though man honestly when you
think about that when you think that a
you know it's never too late and I've
talked about this before but I need this
today I needed it it's never too late to
come over why must we wait when we're
alive and that's a great question
you know I hold myself back from a lot
of things because I don't want to make
that initial move you know I don't want
to make that that attempt I get caught
up in in my feelings and I get and I get
sidetracked from doing what's best for
me even though this is the only time I
get to do it when I'm alive sometimes
sometimes I will pass up on the
opportunity to do something good for
myself like I'm gonna come back a
million times like aw man I'm you know
oh I'm gonna uh you know I'll go swim in
this I'll swim in this boot in this pool
that has a lot of bleach in it don't
matter you know I'll take this hit of
dope don't matter you know I'll take an
extra pain pill while I babysit my
children don't matter but the truth is
many there's instances where those
instances are it making that choice to
say hey man it's now I got to come over
right now knock knock I'm coming over
because I can't I
there's not another I'm alive right now
and right now is when I need to make
some good choices for myself [ __ ] I had
a long weekend good to be here with you
guys I'm sure that you may have as well
and I appreciate you being here with me
if you're watching on the youtubes but
the background is different today all
kinds of [ __ ] has been haywire we got
the Greyhound breakdown
this young man he stood us up last time
I'll be honest dude straight up stood us
up and then today we're supposed to
interview him 3 p.m.
and and I'm this is he and he said five
minutes till three I can't make it some
stuff came up he tells that to my
producer to our producer Chris and then
I was upset I was upset because for one
well you know we pay Chris and Nick to
come I came over and we're there waiting
and we're excited you know we're excited
so that then that kind of lowers our
excitement and he reached out to us
originally when we're looking for a
Greyhound driver so I texted him I said
hey man you know we really want you and
we texted for a minute in the knee he
agreed to come on over and I think he
was maybe nervous and he's a nice kid
nice young man he's a driver bruh
Greyhound thanks for going hound and we
did that episode today and and that'll
be out later this week so thank you guys
man it was uh it was it was interesting
for sure sweet God but you know I had an
instance this week a man I went to New
Jersey and let me say this man some of
the nicest people I met you know New
York always gives New Jersey this rub
like they're not good you know their
smocks a tear you know just a bunch of
hairspray you know test two hundred
junkies just a people and just a bunch
of people in the gym you know
bench-pressing each other and uh and
hidin calzones in their ass you know
they get a lot of that vibe but I look
man all I found was a lot of good people
some good people came out you know
people they had people that were you
know one girl stopped me on the way out
of the show and she just said I just
wanted to think thank you so much for
coming she says you know I I have
anxiety sometimes like you do and you
know you just explain it in a way that
makes me feel you know that makes me
feel
that that that you explain it in a way
that is the same way that I would
explain it
and and she said I appreciate that a man
that just hit me right in the heart you
know it just hit me right in the heart
you know cuz you just I don't know I
just felt a lot of connection a lot of
people that came out and just wanted to
connect for a minute and then we had the
show the show's good look I work hard on
my job and I get him when I'm when you
come to my show I'm gonna do my job you
know I'm gonna do it to the best of my
ability
and and we just had some nice look and I
got there I'll tell you this man I got
to this [ __ ] place bananas it's
called bananas comedy club something in
this place can have a lot of prestige
you know its historical I get there this
[ __ ] in a Holiday Inn okay a
holiday which is basically a Ramada
but with green and white and a little
bit nicer curtains and you know Ramada
is where people get murdered or drugs or
where they have a lot of those
interventions that you see on A&E dude
they don't show you a lot of the signs
but a lot of time as a Ramada or a
Clarion or Hyatt Regency sometimes if
it's a brother on their assist or
someone they meet at a higher Regency
but anyhow or a Crowne Plaza crown
Crowne Plaza but anyhow you know and I
got there and I was [ __ ] pissed man
I'm like this club you know they don't
have a lot of social media you know they
don't have anything in it you know that
in and I'm coming in here and I'm you
know I'm putting ads out I'm spending
money to put ads online just you know
trying to do my best to get the grind
and I was mad because you know why I was
mad cuz I felt like I'm doing all the
work and I come there and this you know
like the staff was great and everything
and it's not a bad place it has a ton of
history it's been there forever but you
know it was just it wasn't it was just a
they rented out a banquet room for the
evening but I was in a bad mood man I
was just [ __ ] pissed you know I was
pissed I guess because you know honestly
I'm like man this was a gig I would've
gone hopefully going to
you know ten years ago when I'm starting
out and you start thinking you know that
I guess you start getting a little in
your brain somewhere you get a little
too big for your britches or your ego
spikes up my ego is like are you better
than you you know you should be you you
know you should but the truth is man and
I texted jay mohr actually I was texting
jay mohr do because you know strange
rabbits jump together and I said man I'm
just I'm pissed dude and he said he
texted back he said man you get you
agreed to do the deal you get paid to
make people laugh and go do your job and
it was what I needed to hear man at the
last moment I did not want to admit that
that's what I needed to hear but that's
what I decided you know it's never too
late man you know it's now I've been
pissed all day I've been angry that I
was you know doing a lot of the extra
work I was doing a lot of the heavy
lifting and they were making a lot of
the money and it just I just want things
to be more fair you know and so but but
once I heard that from Jay man honestly
it just kind of changed me up you know
and I said whatever goes on right now
tonight tomorrow night it's up to my
attitude you know they got people coming
out who want to spend time they got
people coming out that want to laugh you
know I saw some couples come out you
know I met a gal her name's Gina my
mother's name Gina you know I saw a lot
of some Italians you know enough you
know my mother's father was uh he was
Italian
this dude was Italian as [ __ ]
wifebeaters only and had one of those
small combs you comb your hair straight
back with there's only one direction to
comb your hair and that's straight back
and that's full Italian and it reminded
me a little bit of my history and next
thing you know it's like I'm caught up
and I'm caught up in the positive things
you know because I changed my
perspective when I left my room and I
went down to the club because the
[ __ ] club dude
I mean they got doors opening in and out
this [ __ ] they got a wedding going on
next door I'm like what the [ __ ] is
going on but you know what nobody cared
about that nobody in the audience get
all they cared about was that they came
to have a good time and so when I showed
up and I and that's what my goal was man
I felt I felt good because if I show up
the other way and I'm angry and I'm
thinking about you know work or I'm
thinking about you know that that I'm
not being treated fairly or summer you
know if I'm thinking about that kind of
stuff then I ruined that then I ruin it
for then I then I contribute to not
making it a good experience for
everybody and that's the thing you just
never know when you're when how you show
up when you park your car at work you
[ __ ] pissed you hate that dude
Randall that works in the next stall or
whatever
or you hate [ __ ] fat Jerry you know
cuz he nowhere you know he don't wear
any powder or something under on his
skin and he got dirty skin all that [ __ ]
you know if you got to leave that even
if it's at the last minute man when you
want to tell somebody to go [ __ ]
themselves you got to leave it it's
never too late to come over man let's
listen to that ambit one more time
yes
[Music]
why must we wait when we're alive I
didn't wait man I showed up and I had to
bend I had to I had honestly a great
weekend I mean my left my heart was full
man I do this on my night ended Saturday
night I'm sitting out on the bench with
some guy you're the beautiful little guy
and I say little guy but he's you know
this dude's the ultimate package 5 foot
looked like Rudy Ruettiger bro the whole
time he was talking all I saw him doing
was getting one sack at Notre Dame
in the last game ever and and we were
just talking about he said his dad died
of cancer a couple years ago we were
just talking about it we're just
thinking about it and talking about it
and you know my dad passed a cancer dude
it was like you know he was old he's 87
bro you know anything could have got him
you know a strong wind could have took
him down but you know next thing you
know I was sitting there and I was
connecting with somebody and we just had
a good conversation and I just met some
good people man I met so many good
people it saw it was something else what
else man thank you guys for being here
you know thank you guys for being here
this past weekend it is Monday and it's
April 23rd what's going on I got I
what's going on let me think about
what's going on yeah I've just been
feeling just I guess you know I didn't
take my medicine yesterday and so and
then I didn't take it today because I
was on a plane all morning and I guess I
may be whining but you know and I've
been at the studio for about four or
five hours and so I've just been in a
tough just been in a tough mood you know
in my it's just hard man when you don't
take your medicine you kind of dependent
upon that it takes a lot of correct in
the do takes a lot you got to correct
yourself often you know you got a [ __ ]
refocus because things get blurry but
I'm happy to be with you guys today man
in some ways I haven't really been
taking that great care of myself you
know I got kind of lonely I guess on
Friday and ended up you know jerkin out
dude spraying out full you know doing
that full body sauce you know making
that self sauce in my room
and I didn't want to man you know that's
the crazy part you know when I was young
I wanted to jerk off you know if I saw
somebody anybody it could be a
hitchhiker did I be driving down the
road if I even saw a hitchhiker I would
just jerk off in my passenger seat you
know even if they weren't in the car or
nothing you know just as like a sign of
respect you know I'm saying anything I
would masturbate at anything a full moon
bruh I masturbate a half moon no moon
clouds whatever [ __ ] I'm jerking off
you know and I was just fired up like
that I was keyed up about my own dick
you know I was a hundred percent excited
but then now man these you know and it's
it is the dark arts man and you think
it's gone and you even start to think
it's a riddle it's a joke you know the
dark arts but it's not because I'm
laying there in my room and I'm thinking
to myself it was like 1:30 in the
morning and I didn't want to jerk off in
fact the only thing I didn't want to do
was jerk off anything else in the room I
would have done masturbating was not in
my plan 45 seconds later I had jerked
off just like that dude it's like
lightning and I don't know what causes
it sometimes I really don't know you
know I just know that when it comes to
some of that stuff I got to refocus
because the truth is it's some feeling
inside of me where I want to I just want
to do something to myself I just want to
do something I want to do a drug I want
to you know throw a rock through an old
old man's Oh through a haunted house
window you know what I'm saying I want
to [ __ ] you know give an old lady a
hickey I want to do something naughty I
want to do something naughty and so I
just act out and before I know it it's
gone something like an electricity comes
through me and I behave a certain way
ah so anyway and then dude honestly I'll
be full honest did I jerked off last
night so I doubled up you know I went
through that hard weekend you know I
went through that you know it was two
for two you know I'm like
I'm like Anthony Davis brah I was you
know just hitting buckets every time I
try to jerk off I succeeded and I don't
know man I don't know where I'm at with
that that's the crazy part I don't even
know where I'm at with that but I guess
I just wanted to bring it up because I
know there's people going out there that
are struggling with it
I met a dude at the show dude said hey
man I got 11 10 days I got 10 days clean
off that here k jerky you know off that
[Music]
you know so he said he got 10 days clean
I said hey man good luck out there
you know you carrying the banner for all
of us because I got about seven or eight
hours clean so it just persists man you
know and my problems persist cuz I don't
want to sometimes I don't want to I
don't want to make that move that I know
that I need to do and try and get ahead
of it and some of y'all are out there
like dude who gives a [ __ ] just jerk off
well listen to this
whoever saying that I've been jerking
off my whole life and I don't want to
anymore you hear me what if I told you
stop doing something and you said you
would and then a few minutes later you
did it well that's what's happening just
so you know what's going on on my end
so yeah I guess I'm just feeling a
little down the dance with some of that
stuff you know because it makes me feel
at a certain point man I've been talking
about this [ __ ] dude if you go back if
you go back to the first episode I've
been talking about try to quit Church
and Here I am like in a year and half
later still talking about it man Who am
I what am i what am I
I don't know but that's one thing you
know it's it's never too late to give up
you know to not give up it's never too
late to you know find a new avenue to
chase it you know it's never too late
and that's what I think that song is
about with Stevi starlight you know even
at the last minute even when you're in
the doldrums even if you you know you
addicted to opiates or you you know
you've been cheating on your girl are
you you know you've been lying to your
parents you know that's never too late
to be free you know that a young dude
this weekend he came to the show and he
sent me a DM later on and he said hey
man you know I'm just I've been going
through a real real tough time he said
and it seemed like everything that I do
is the wrong thing and man it just
really uh because this was a young guy
you know this guy's maybe 21 22 years
old
Manesh it makes me and it just hurt me
you know cuz he's a young guy and he you
know you don't realize when someone when
you're a little younger that even though
things are heaviest not they're not
detrimental to your whole life that you
still have so much life ahead that
there's always opportunities to make
things okay and uh and yeah that's what
I messaged in my two semesters I said
hey man you know and he brought his
brother to the show and that's what kind
of got me about these two man is that
they were brothers you know and you guys
know I love that kind of stuff man if
you got a brother like you know my
brother was never we weren't close when
I was young and so it's been a new
experience for me getting to have a
brother and getting to have that growth
and you know uh you know there's getting
to share my feelings with somebody
that's so close to me and a level that
is just intangible you know a level
that's just you know a level that's just
epic
you know that's at the weave at the
weave of my soul you know we are the
same textile and you know and so then
there's do it just because I was like oh
he's here with his brother everything's
cool and then later the guys in this
message him you know what just hit me
hard and I said hey man you know it's
never anything is going on your life you
cannot you can solve it with um with
just trying to be honest you know trying
to get honest with yourself or if you
wrong somebody being honest with them
you know full honesty just let them know
some honest so it's crazy sometimes our
like ways we can just be you know just
scared to do what's right I don't know
what that is inside of us I don't know
if it's in all of us but I know that it
to me sometimes but uh but yeah cinnamon
he didn't message me back but I'm you
know I'm I know he's got her brother so
I know that at the very least he's got
one person out there you know really
looking out for him and taking care of
him so that's a solid news what else man
what else is going on I you know I
didn't tell you guys everything really I
went home last weekend and you know we
had the episode with the transgender
person who was on this past weekend the
last interview I think it's episode 89
and Robin Tran is her name and when I
didn't realized even during the
conversation they were talking like
she'd ever had a surgery she just felt
like a woman
and so then became a woman and you know
I kind of wish I'd gotten into more
questions about well if you don't have
the surgery what does that mean or you
you know but I guess in the end does it
[ __ ] matter you know does it I mean
at the end she feels comfortable or he
feels comfortable as a woman I can
relate to that [ __ ] sometimes dude
sometime I want to be a big girl you
know sometimes I want to eat a snow cone
in the rain sometimes I want to lay in
bed and snack the [ __ ] out you know
sometime I just want a hot Oreos in my
[ __ ] ass and vagina or whatever you
know in my body sometimes I just want my
beasts breast feed a [ __ ] that I
don't know and sometimes I want to be a
big girl and put barrettes in my hair
sometimes I just want to be that for a
second but it shakes out
me it's just a phase it's a quick Wow
you ever get that ghost runs through
your body uh-huh that's how it happens
to me but he might have got caught by
that ghost you know you just don't know
you just don't know I didn't really tell
you guys the truth about you know I went
back home to my hometown and you know we
had an interview set up with people and
all these people and I had this this
feeling I was scared that I was uh I
don't know I guess I was scared that I
was bothering people you know by having
them come an interview with me and be a
part of this project we were doing I was
like not I want to waste people's time
and I guess I thought that you know
inside of me I thought that people
thought I was dumb you know where people
thought I was stupid or what's this
you know goofy guy coming and uh and
making fun of you know or not making fun
but is he you know what's he you know
this guy's a weirdo you know those are
the thoughts that I had and so I was
kind of embarrassed the whole time I was
in town you know I was kind of um I
don't know I guess I just maybe I guess
I felt like maybe the people there would
think that I was your too fancy or too
you know we're better than them or
something when really the truth was I
was feeling like I was feeling yeah I
guess I was feeling like that that they
I would be I was scared of that Oh would
they're gay you know with but then the
truth was that people wanted to help out
and people weren't mean people are
actually extremely helpful you know and
here I had this a chip on my shoulder
like you know people were gonna you know
what is it you know this kid you know he
lives in Los Angeles now in Hollywood he
thinks he's gonna come back to town he's
you know you know who does he think he
is I had this weird I had this story
going on in my head but you know who you
know who made that story me because the
truth is the facts were that I went in I
went home and I brought a lot of people
from different places and then we
had a good time and that people were
more than helpful this one guy we
interviewed and I was a little bit
nervous because I didn't know him he's a
friend of Mines that I grew up with his
brother and we drove out I mean middle
of nowhere out to his home and we
interviewed with him and we're texting
later on and I was the hole I'm like the
whole time were there shooting at his
house I'm like Lizzie I'm telling the
crew like let's hurry up and get out of
here you know I don't want to waste his
time like I'm you know I want him at
that you know and then I'll leave and in
the next day I just texted him and say
hey man thank you so much and he said no
worries man
I was really happy to do it I just
wanted I just wanted to make y'all proud
and I was like man it just blew my mind
because the truth of the scenario was
was uh was what he said and was what he
did he come you know what everybody did
it they helped out and the lie of the
scenario was whatever was living in my
head it was some fear of mine I'm afraid
these people don't accept me I'm afraid
that you know some kids that picked on
me 20 years ago are still gonna be
picking on me now and the truth was dude
I went back to my hometown and I made
three or four new friends people that I
had never even known and and a couple of
I'm still texting with nough and it just
you know I don't know just my own fears
were just keeping me from my own choice
and now if I could go back knowing that
the people just wanted to they wanted to
help me out
you know they wanted to be supportive
you know which is they wanted to be
supportive and it just uh if I could go
back now and try and live whatever the
truth was which was that people were
being helpful instead of living this
this fear this lie in my head
God you know I think I could have made
the most of it all of that experience so
yeah you know and I wasn't dishonest
about that but I knew that that was on
my heart when I got on the podcast and I
just didn't share it and I didn't talk
about it and you know I like this to be
a
so I can kind of share what's going on
with me and you know cuz you guys do you
guys call in you know you guys are so
supportive man some of the support I got
this weekend you know just excited
people excited to see me you know it
just makes me feel good man you know it
just makes me feel good I guess it makes
me feel good you know and I'm excited to
see them you know I'm excited to see you
know people wait around after the show
to the line you know and we and I try to
take them you know a minute or so with
each person cuz you know there's people
waiting in line and the whole time I'm
thinking man the last people in the line
they probably have a babysitter and
they're having to pay extra because they
want to wait in line you know and uh
that kind of stuff I know there's
something about me I hate I always feel
like I'm wasting people's time I think
that's what it all goes back to I think
that's what it goes back to with you
know being scared of going back home and
you know hurrying up the interviews and
stuff because I feel like I'm always
wasting people's time you know there's
something inside of me I don't know when
it started or when it happened but you
know I was afraid to speak up or I was
afraid to you know just be whoever I was
are afraid to you know care about people
are afraid to do anything probably
because I was afraid somehow of wasting
their time you know I was afraid
yeah I'm just afraid sometimes of wait
that I'm wasting people's time that's
crazy isn't it
it's such a strange fear that can live
inside of somebody and just control so
much of their life anyway man I didn't
mean to get all weirdo and stuff but you
know I felt like I just some episodes I
come in and I'm hyped up and I feel like
I got to entertain and I don't want to
always feel like that honestly cuz
that's not where I want to live you know
I want to live in a place where I feel
like I can you know if we doing one we
doing one if it's entertaining it's
entertaining
but if it's emotionally draining its
emotionally draining we either tain in
her drain and you know what else I you
know we got a couple of good episodes in
we got a couple of neat things coming
out I want to tell you as well about you
know it great block pizza and that's our
charter sponsor man and they're great
dude if you don't like great block then
you don't know about life imagine you uh
imagine you are going to heaven and you
get to heaven okay you felt you know you
died on earth or you passed away let's
say you passed away because it sounds
better than dying and you passed away in
your body just floating up through the
cat up through the clouds and and you
get to heaven right and you come back
into consciousness and you open your
mouth and you taste something amazing
that's great block pizza boy 18:11 Pico
Boulevard on the way to the beach you
know what it is get that also you know
it that this podcast is brought to you
by this new item called the ridge wallet
I carry that bulky that bulky wallet and
I already got a big ass you know what
I'm saying I'm built like a black girl
with D s from the waist down I got that
hoop you know I got that Jay in the tray
you have had me and if that big bulky
wallet man I sit lopsided you know so
I'll get scoliosis spina bifida neck
scarring everything but now that I have
that Ridge it's that minimalist front
pocket item you can put your credit
cards your cash you know you can stack
it up make it nice put it in your pocket
be fresh at the club don't look like
your [ __ ] grandfather you you know
walking around with that big ass ass
cheek you know where he's by the time
you six you got that heavy ass wallet
you got all kind of receipts in there
[ __ ] who needs receipts
nobody does their taxes like that it
ain't 1989 listen here mf'er okay do
your stuff online like a natural human
be fully natural no more pointless stuff
no more that first condom you used you
know no more that uh Dave & Buster's
card that's been in there for
years [ __ ] it expired after 90 days
toss it or keep all your cards but keep
them in one of the titanium carbon fiber
or aluminum options that come from the
ridge it's a minimal front pocket wallet
designed to let you ditch your bulky
wallet the ridges wallet is slim
rfid-blocking and lifetime guaranteed
it's the last wallet you'll ever buy and
you can get 10% off today with free
worldwide shipping that means if you're
in Nicaragua okay you're hiding or
you're in the witness protection program
anywhere they will still ship go to
Ridge wallet calm slash Theo
that's Ridge wallet calm slash Theo and
use promo code Theo for 10% off let's
get into some calls maybe you guys have
some great calls that came in I'm gonna
tell you about a few dates really fast
and then we'll cruise into it I'm sure
you know it's been man it's been a long
couple of weeks and you know what when I
stop and think that I'm grateful it
makes everything okay you know when I'm
just riding through everything and I'm
frustrated I'm texting and I'm angry
about this and I'm waiting to hear about
that and all all those feelings that I'm
having that's all my [ __ ] and it's never
too late for me to come right over and
close my eyes and just be grateful be
grateful to some higher power out there
that I'm alive that I got love in my
heart if I want to give it and then I
got somebody out there somebody that
cares
somebody there's somebody out there that
cares about you and if you don't think
you got it [ __ ] I'll be it I
promise you that man I make hugs boy I'm
a straight up hug make her son
bang bang Oh hug these ain't arms boy
these [ __ ] hug collectors ho
BAM all right let's get into a couple of
dates I got I'll see you guys at cluster
fest and that's in San Francisco June
2nd and 3rd I believe or the nights I'm
performing I'll be at Cherokee Casino
why aren't the tickets online people
keep asking me I don't know I've asked
them twice so call them up at Cherokee
West silo amore wherever it is and tell
them to put the [ __ ] online June 15th
and 16th and I'll be at Calgary at Yuk
Yuk's come out there Brendan Schaub was
just there
come and see daddy Garrett daddy bear
get in there and growl at your mama's
cat gang they don't be a temblor brewing
where Brendan Schaub just was as well
and that's June 23rd gang July 6th 7th
and 8th they'll be at levity live in
Oxnard and what else we got some other
dates that'll be hitting I'm trying to
drop this tour this week I think the
website's almost done Saul put those
dates up ASAP for that dark arts tour
thank you again to everybody that came
out in Hasbrouck Heights boy everybody
came through a lot of stunners a lot of
killers and we did it and we did it
ok let's get into some calls you guys
hit me and I'm gonna share that right
now here we go
[Music]
I'm calling from go high school Ali from
Glasgow and let me tell you guys this
man if you don't know this they have a
band out there called The Pogues and I
believe they're Scottish and then you
have a beautiful voice ally and I want
to tell you that I love your accent
immediately I was smiling this might be
the first time I was smiled this episode
and you just did that for me so thank
you but there's a band called The Pogues
and one of my old roommates this man
Kevin and I just sleep under his bed for
$150 and when I first moved out here to
Los Angeles and that was non-central
that was just practical and you know
fully straight male natural and I would
be under his bed just red just resting
you know and anyhow he knew the lead
singer of The Pogues this man named
Shane MacGowan and he one night Shane
was performing in El
and he took me over to the Sunset
Marquis which is this little hideaway
hotel and I went back in and sat in this
living room and the lights were all out
in there except for a lamp and somebody
came in the manager of Shane MacGowan
came in took some sort of a drug into
the next room you heard somebody do a
couple of a couple of busts of it and
then bang next thing you know I'm
sitting there in the living room with
Shane MacGowan of The Pogues and my
buddy told him I did comedy and so he
goes cuz that's how he talks and he's
done so much drugs everything he don't
have much talk left in and what sounds
real full sounds he sounds more like a
um you know he sound like an animal but
you know like a angry animal but with
you know maybe mild to heavy autism or
tis 'm for short you know and also
autism I think is French maybe I'm not
even sure anyhow so next thing I'm doing
performing for Shane MacGowan
in a lamp lit lobby of a lamp lit living
room of a of a hotel room in the Sunset
Marquis and at the end he just goes that
was him laughing but he I know he's a UH
he's a bit of an icon there in Scotland
and I guess that was kind of a humble
brag but it was also the strangest time
I'd ever perform for someone and the
strangest sound that a person had ever
made back at me okay here we go for the
rest of your call Ollie I love your
chest and I just wanted to let you know
that you've got people laughing from all
over the world and Kim Yellin baby's at
the Edinburgh Festival and oh is this
cheering anybody else up this this uh
this call I mean this calls minkum he
feel great I just picked her like I'm
just such a big fan of um James J
Braddock you know and that was in the
butter's Cinderella Man or butter it's a
butterfly man butterfly
man and he is about it's about a man who
is a I guess he's like an ironworker
something he gets a chance to fight
somebody he gets a chance to fight a
Jewish man and they've just beat each
other and it's um it's uh but I think he
has a Scottish accent I think let's hear
more it's a different life right here
and then what you talk about and I love
Peter you talk about Jimmy Giano
and it's where he came from because it's
just not a station maker that you fill
up fascinates me so much and your
respective sweet boy and I really hope
fate will for you I'm just once
I'm almost two little boys here at six
and four oh man this you get you get me
here Ali that's so sweet of you you know
there's something interesting when
somebody of a different accent tells you
says something nice doesn't it resonates
differently do you think it's because we
just don't hear it like if somebody you
know like she says you know that you're
a sweet boy you know I just made it made
me feel good you know and I don't know
if it's just something buddy sometimes
someone with an accent or something
that's different it just makes you feel
good I can't even explain myself but I
go on Ali you got two children they're
six and four I believe let's hear that
part again two little boys here are six
and four and can thank unfortunately you
work in a plant huh and it pays the
bills that's awesome
good for you you know I bet those boys
are gonna be really proud of you
you know I'll say this my mother fell
the other day and she hurt her hip and
uh and I feel bad you know I can't be
there to help her out you know I can if
she needs it you know I mean I can help
out financially from where I am I've got
some weeks coming off so maybe I'll buzz
down for a weekend and see if I can if I
can help her I'll ask her if she wants
help even though I know she's gonna say
no you know there's something about her
she just doesn't
I was willing to admit that she needs
help and and it's crazy when we admit
that we need help man it just it opens
up so much inside of us because there's
something about holding on to not one
people to help you because if you don't
want people to help you then the crazy
part is they can't they can't no matter
how hard they try or do you can't feel
it that's the crazy thing if you don't
want if I don't I can do it I can do
I'll do it must I can I can do it then
you can't then even if they do you can't
feel it and the greatest part about
somebody helping you I have found I'm
not preaching at you I'm just saying for
me that I've started to find is not
whatever they do for you but it's the
feeling you get that somebody cared but
you sound like just an amazing mother
Ali are you give them their are you
married as well I'm not hitting on you
here but I just wanted to know I'll play
that back a second for you I'm a mom of
two little boys here are six and four
and can thank unfortunately both and my
sister bailed in a nice straight line
and a really nice video in high school
and I'm really happy I mean your foot
just makes me really happy I just wanted
to leave a message and tell you that
yeah you're forecasters 101 zwickler
Jeremy Wow thanks Ali
that's sweet of you but I bet those boys
are gonna be proud of you you know I
couldn't tell if you were married or not
I didn't hear that I couldn't some of
your accent I couldn't understand but
that's okay it's a beautiful sound you
make but but those boys are gonna be
proud of because you know it's funny
like my mother-in-law's connection is
it's tough but you know I realized the
other day that she she's just one that
she's the hardest-working man that I
know he's my mother and she fell as you
heard herself and she has to be down for
like a month and she's just upset
and I don't know what to do really to
make her feel better you know I mean I
can tell her that I love her and tell
her that I care but I just I don't know
I wish there was something I could do to
make her feel better
you know I can pray for you know and and
see if maybe some of that helps and I
can take some action I'll find some
things to do I was thinking maybe I'll
see if there's like a fresh fruit
company that could Center some fruit
because I'm sure if you laid up you know
it might be good a couple of them Harry
and David payers and if you don't know
about that company I don't work for them
but that's a couple of gay men I believe
that sent fruit to people around America
and that's gay as hell but that's also
beautiful snacks Thank You Alan let's
hear another call yeah and my name is
Billy and I'm 25 years old from Sweden
oh wait and before um and actually you
know I wanted to know who is listening
and that's why Ali called you know she
you know cuz that last week I said who's
listening to this podcast and you can
always hit the hotline and just let me
know who's listening you we might put it
on we might not nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three as well if
you've hit the hotline and it hasn't
gotten on sometimes it's just life
there's nothing it's hard to even listen
to every single call but everyone gets
listened to but yeah we just wanted to
know who listens who listens to the
podcast and Thank You Ali for calling in
here we go let's start that call over
Billy I do and my name is Billy and I'm
25 years old from Sweden Wow we're
getting international today thank you
for calling Billy you sound a little
older than 25 you sound like a wise boy
and I've been living in California for
about four years and at the same time as
California was the rescue of my life and
and shitshow of drugs and alcohol and my
depression and suicidal thoughts have to
come back deep man I'm sorry to hear
that brother sorry to hear that
onward these last couple of weeks
I'm seeing therapists now and I'm doing
all right well thank you for calling
Billy you know it's uh I feel you I do
feel you and sometimes we'd only want to
hear that and I don't know what you want
to hear you know I don't know if you
want um you know I don't know if you
just want somebody to listen I don't
know if you want somebody to relate
sometimes when I share something
somebody I don't even want them to
relate you know I don't know what I want
I don't know if I want them to
understand I don't know if I just want
to don't want to be the only person
that's feeling what I'm feeling so I'll
be even just put it on somebody else's
plate and after I do I can't even hear
what they say cuz I don't [ __ ] care
because I'm so you know lost in whatever
my illness is or my mental illness at
the moment but I appreciate you calling
and sharing this - you know I spend a
lot of time in Los Angeles when I was in
my 20s actually just not caring I you
know I hated myself you know I was party
and I was doing things I didn't want to
be doing you know I was making choices
that didn't make me feel good and and it
can be a really tough place especially
when you throwing drugs and alcohol
because this is a lonely city even the
animals are [ __ ] lonely out here
there's no big happy dogs they're all
little cold animals that don't even
exist if you go east of the Mississippi
most of these animals don't even exist
they're little like you know a mini be a
mini Bichon Oodle like what is that
that's a [ __ ] it's like a you know
it's not a real dog some of these things
they're things that are cross bred in
these fancy shops and hair shops out
here in the basements of these fancy
hair shops they're crossbreeding little
animals you know the cross cross B breed
a [ __ ] Doberman with a arm with a
mouse you know and you got a dough brows
and then they're selling that [ __ ] for
$3,000 on dark web on the doggie doggie
dark web if a frisbee will kill that
it's not a dog that's what I say
if you tore frisbee to it and it [ __ ]
tries to catch it and it dies guess what
you know what it's not a dog but I feel
you Billy I feel that and you know what
if I could go back into my time when I
was feeling that way I would get out
more and move around more you know that
that that darkness for me it was a it
was like a moss that grows on a tree and
the more I stayed in the dark the more
it was able to grow but when I got out
and took care of myself and walked in
the Sun and moved around and when I met
up with a friend for lunch even though I
didn't want to and when I actually went
on a date instead of just jerked off at
the house and cancelled at the last
minute when I actually did him thanks
you know and set off and pop pop the
little man I've really actually enjoyed
it because you'll get addicted to being
in that circle you know misery loves
company so once you start to feel
miserable you start you get addicted to
being miserable I'm not saying you are I
know the drugs and the alcohol those
kind of things don't help because those
are you know at the after-effects of
those it's depressants you know so for
that type of stuff you may want to check
you know see if you need some treatment
stop buying a meeting and a make a a
meeting or al-anon meeting those are
always great because you get to go sit
in there make sure it's a speaker
meeting you get to go sit in there and
listen to somebody share their life and
you listen for the similarities not the
differences and those can sometimes make
help you feel will help you get back in
touch with your feelings but look man
you sound like the kind of guy we need
here I mean you're from Sweden dude
Sweden supposed to be real cool you know
what do they got over there bobsled and
teddy bears I saw a picture of um some
people one time from Sweden and they had
about six people in the pitch room damn
three of them at teddy bears I mean
Jesus if 50% of people in y'all's
country running around with stuffed
animals
whoo that's some [ __ ] huggable
geographic locations that sounds just
admirable
so yeah you got to find some ways to
feel better man Los Angeles is tough
though this is not a very connected city
man this is not a very connected city at
all and you got to really want it you
got to get out there and want it but let
me know why don't you text text the
hotline Billy if you want to come out to
a show come meet me at a comedy show one
night you know the sit come sit in the
crowd with me they will laugh you know
you don't have to if you don't that's
okay but when people do invite you to do
stuff don't always say no because if I
could go back in time and say yes a few
times even though it wasn't what I
wanted to do I wanted to say no I wanted
to stay in my bed I wanted to just you
know not take care of myself
but that contrary action when you don't
want to I don't want I got off the plane
today man
I caught uh you know I caught a plane
this morning out of JFK dude at 7:30
okay I get here to LA all I wanted to do
is rest but I [ __ ] went to a yoga
class and it was a piece of [ __ ] it was
bunch of old ladies laying around on
these little Sam balls and I [ __ ]
wanted to shoot the place up not with a
gun that was like a nerf gun but a
hard-ass nerf gun that would have left
some bruises on some real [ __ ] in
there but I didn't I stayed in the class
until I had to leave to come here and I
showed up and then when the guy was
supposed to come and do the Greyhound
episode he [ __ ] canceled at the last
minute I sat in my chair and I lost my
mind for 30 seconds and then I just
turned it around I wanted to say [ __ ]
everybody you know and put a damn
cigarette through my wrist but I didn't
because if I keep doing those behaviors
I'm not helping me I'm not helping that
little me inside of me that really does
want to do something different so you're
not alone man love you bro keep your
head up
text me up on the on the hotline I'll
call I'll bring you out to a show man be
my guest
and we'll chop it up huh and don't feel
like it's gonna be weird dude you know
I've had same feelings you're okay we're
all so similar man [ __ ] scary
thank you for calling bud keep your head
here we go another call hey this is a
Duncan from Denver Colorado
last weekend went out with some friends
for a little bachelor party hey Duncan
calling her from that altitude and you
don't know people from the high altitude
could say anything you don't even know
he could be sleepwalking right now you
know you get up to high altitudes
anything can happen people training
crows [ __ ] you know trying to lasso
clouds crazy [ __ ] up there that's goat
country let's hear more we ended up
going to a strip club
well the whole story story ended up
running into my ex-girlfriend behold my
girlfriend found out about it I haven't
seen my ex-girlfriend in probably five
six years I didn't know she was gonna be
there I didn't expect it to happen I
can't be that guy that just gets up and
leaves his friend's bachelor party at a
strip club because his ex-girlfriend's
they're stripping but I did get it a
dancer dude didn't take her home not
like that and my girlfriend come out and
she's counting it as cheating I don't
think it is I couldn't help the fact she
was there what's your opinion you know I
just started reading this book called
sex at dawn and it's by a man named
Chris Ryan and I just started and uh and
I've literally read through the
introduction and I mean just in the
first chapter I'm it just started
yesterday
Anna read slow and I don't wanna [ __ ] I
almost don't like the book because it's
really some of the stuff it's saying is
just stuff that I don't want to hear you
know it's saying that you know marriage
isn't sacred and that our sexuality that
our our behaviors are actual not are not
really in line with our beliefs and I
don't want to believe that even though
there probably is some truth to it but
I've decided that I'm gonna finish
reading the book even though I don't
already don't agree with some of the
[ __ ] in there because how else am I
gonna be how else am I gonna learn you
know how else am I gonna learn if I
don't try to at least experience
something different now if it gets
[ __ ] crazy you know we're
people are you know tasting each other's
hair and you know trying to steal each
other's eyesight and [ __ ] like that some
of these intergalactic stories I'm out
I'm out but but I'm gonna stay and watch
i'ma staying listen on that story and
read on that story and and I'll say this
man look is it cheating nah doesn't
sound like cheating doesn't something
cheating at all if you got some lap
dances from her I don't know what your
relationship setup is like with your
lady but if she's upset and that's
really where that's where it ends and
your thing now is how do you make her
feel better you know I I do think it was
probably a little bit classless to do
that with your ex girlfriend be honest
with you might not be what you want to
hear you know if you want to get
something from another girl and go get
that you know if you want to get a lap
dance for another girl you are at a
strip club but the guys it's kind of a
you know some of that's like you know
when you know when in Rutgers you know
find you a slam pig and have a [ __ ]
beef sandwich you know when at Rutgers
but but look if that's you know if
that's not the kind of setup yet with
your girl why'd you do it that's what I
want to know why'd you do it were you
missing this old girl where you want to
relive a fantasy is there something
you're missing in your own relationship
you know
were you upset at your girl about
something and you knew she would get
upset those are the questions I would
start to ask myself cuz there's a reason
why you did it but yet should you
girlfriend be upset I don't know if she
should she is though that's the thing
and what do they say you know heaven
hath no fear like a woman scorned so you
know that [ __ ] boy good luck there
Duncan Oh Martin hey Paul Boston I want
to place on my past weekend so I had a
little okay this is Paul from Boston and
this pass telling us about his past
weekend that's a contest we do every
month you can call in leave a 62nd or
less voicemail about your past weekend
try to make it 60 seconds if that [ __ ]
goes way over you're out and each month
we'll pick the best one and we'll give
you a
we'll send you one of these t-shirts and
a couple of sweet hitters that we got
over here homework today sped up going
to see the the rogen comedy specials on
the Wilbert so we go across great before
now he's saying they had a tender date
set up and he's going to see the comedy
the Joe Rogan special over at the Wilbur
here we go and he's going with a tender
date so they went to have dinner and get
to know each other more
I'm having drinks like a normal person
have one or two this little lady a brown
bear is down in drinks like their water
oh yeah dude one of them Worcester
warlords right there boy they got some
real butter monsters out there from
North Worcester onward so I started
noticing she's getting a little strong
starting to feel this up a little bit we
go to another farmer for shown here Oh
somebody's and I realized he is hammered
and this is not looking too hot no yeah
I saw a girl like that last week man and
one of her eyes kind of shuts down when
she drinks like damn she just turns into
this straight-up just vodka Cyclops you
know we get to the show and she's never
been to a comedy Sybil forest no Tony
hitch brothers doing this thing at the
open-air tops of jokes and she starts
yelling out in the crowd thinking she's
a part of it it's like oh dude there's
nothing worse than that there's nothing
worse then when you fly across the
country to do your work in some loud
[ __ ] tries to turn your show into an
open mic come on
more like yeah be doing that and during
juice security has a doctor gets this
one where she's in the bathroom
security talk at me and then we got
looked at me she's like hey she's been
picked out so I always downstairs and
she's disappeared and I still don't know
where she ended up I have her her phone
case their wallet and everything and
this right here back from her 24 hours
later is this dude trying to make a
murder for alibi
for a murder is this dude trying to make
an alibi for a murder he just said he
took a woman to the Joe Rogan comedy
show she was loud they threw her out and
he still has her phone case and and
hasn't seen her in her shoes or whatever
lipsticks good Christ brother dude this
ain't that kind of hotline you calling
in for I mean you might want to call a
dang I don't know who you call an
attorney there this sound like the dark
arts man I don't even know if we should
respond to this she's missing I mean
it's just a missing person who because
this isn't you know 9-1-1 you know this
is 984 this is ninety five six six four
nine five zero three that's the hotline
Oh
dangerous dates dude I took a girl out
one night to the seafood place she had a
seizure right because I guess some kind
of crab meat makes her [ __ ] shakedown
and so she took a couple of [ __ ] hits
at at her chin to the face and bam she
was on the concrete but she bounced back
up you know it was a brief seizure one
of those you know maybe a 3.4 on the
human Richter and she popped back up you
know about six seconds later and we
chilled a little bit and then she
started drinking vodka redbulls and we
ended up making love so you never know
kind of you never know how ill somebody
is and you never know where love can
strike what else here we go hey my name
is Matt I live here at the what's up
Matt you live in Los Angeles
how are you recovering heroin addict I
got three years coming up Wow
bro you got three years wow man that's
awesome dude I appreciate you sharing
that that makes me feel good dude
somebody did something for three years
nobody could do something for three
years
that's awesome man I'm May 26 May 25th
alright you're looking about a month in
three days I just I'm feeling kind of
lost in my life right now you know kind
of job obviously you know making ends
meet paying the bills but I just I don't
have a career I know I don't know where
I want to go with my life and I don't
know which direction to go with it now I
have things that I'm passionate about
but the motivation it's just not there I
feel that I'm stuck in this rut of this
perpetual cycle of routine and I just
can't find a way out of it and I'm just
I'm hoping that maybe I could hear some
words of wisdom from behind Theo von
thanks Matt I don't have much wisdom
dude you not only have only almost two
years of coming up on sobriety and it's
not from heroin you know and I can't
imagine what that's like to kick do do
not commend you I know there's a lot of
people out there right now who are
riding that white horse you know in the
mopes boy hopping up on them up beyond
uh you know I feel you sometimes I feel
you that it's tough to know direction
especially when there's so many
influences nowadays in so many
sensations and so many so much
availability it's hard to know kind of
what your calling is but it sounds like
there's a big positive in that you know
you said you have a job you're making
ends meet you're obviously you care
about what your future looks like right
now which I don't maybe you did three
years ago to you know when you reuse him
but now I don't know you probably cared
about it then but you probably weren't
you were probably less sure of it so
yeah it seemed like you know you're in a
real spot right now to kind of get to
some other levels you know to kind of
really find some direction and sometimes
sometimes it's a waiting game sometimes
it's an action
you know you tell you try something new
you don't know I was acting on this
pilot the other day and I just you know
got into act and enough made it some big
mistakes unsaid and you know is I'm
gonna learn on the fly and uh you know
it was it was painful was tough it was a
tough one of the toughest days I've had
working ever and uh and there was a girl
that was there doing background work and
I know her she works at the Comedy Store
and I saw her and I was just so excited
to see her and she said you know I've
been thinking about doing background
work or acting for a long time and stuff
said I finally just have to try it and I
was like well good for you because
there's things that I've thought about
over the years you know running a bakery
starting a coffee shop you know
inventing like this new kind of light
switch that is like kind of a little bit
smaller than some of the light switches
we use and then one that is also a lot
bigger that you can find at night
because at night I have a tough time you
know locating that switch like why put
such a little [ __ ] switch when we
need really a bigger switch and so you
know I've been wanting to do this thing
but I never did them so maybe try them
one thing you know instead of you know
fear in the directions try one thing see
what you like see what you don't maybe
you'll find it hey at least I like a
little bit of this a sense of this
there's a test as well you know what
there's a test that really helped me out
let me see if I can find it right now
that man's name Gary one of the smartest
men that I know sent me this thing Gary
white he'll and he said to me um let me
see what he said here he said the Kolbe
there's something called the Kolb Kol ve
a type test kol ve a the letter a /t y
PE test and he said take that test and
you'll learn some insights about
yourself and you you can't it's not
something you can sit and just take you
know when you have 20 minutes you need
like an hour you need to sit and focus
on it and Andrea some of the words and
the questions are big and you have to
think about yourself you might have to
read some definitions to really get the
questions
right but that that helped me realize
some things that test helped me realize
look man you are not good at the
intricacies of things you're not good at
producing the stuff you can you're good
at being creative but when it comes to
producing you need help otherwise you're
gonna try to put it on your table and
you're not gonna eat you're gonna put it
all on your table but you're not gonna
eat and and so I've learned that about
myself and that test helped me learn
that because it was true the second I
heard it I knew it was true and maybe it
sounds like that's some of the stuff
you're looking for just like just a
couple of truths because I think if you
can start with some small truths and you
can build up some more certainty and you
know it's really tough for people that
have struggled with addiction I find and
I know it's been tough for me to know
what is an instinct and what is a desire
and what is uh you know just kind of
when I'm unsure and when I'm just scared
it's just tough to know what my feelings
are because I've just started feeling
them for so long I repressed them for so
long and I didn't even know I was
repressing them but now I'm just
learning to feel them so it's almost
like my feelings all have training
wheels on them so it's scary sometimes
to try something new because I'm like is
this just a crazy whim or is this a real
desire and that can be really scary
sometimes but look man all I can say is
I'm proud of you for thinking about it
and you know you did one of the things
that I'm learning that I did today man I
was so upset about something I called my
sponsor and I asked him I said I just
need some help you know and it was nice
because when I got the phone I didn't
feel this bad and so maybe that's a
thing you know call someone who knows
more than you do
I wish I was that person today I just I
don't know I don't think I am but I know
that you're not alone so don't feel like
that you know there's people out there
that are 60 70 they don't know but I do
know if there's something I need to
finally ground myself if I try and make
somebody else feel better or do
something for someone else even if it's
just a phone call or anything that
usually always helps put me in a little
bit better place
but I wish you well Matt and
congratulations on that three years
coming up in May
last call on common rural North Carolina
what's up Tom in rural North Carolina
and he was one of our original callers
used to call all the time thank you for
calling back Tom I kind of thank you man
I don't know of you you still like to be
screened or you listen to him alone but
you're gonna have to hear this I want
you to know that uh you know without you
man I probably would be dead I mean
thanks to some of the things you said
I've reached out and you know went to
therapy and you know my life it's not
great nobody's life sucks great but it's
a lot better and you know I sometimes I
can hear the frustration where you going
through and you know sometimes you just
you truck so hard forward though you
don't look behind and see how far you've
come and I was listening to a lot of the
older stuff and it's just crazy to see
how far you come with just the fan base
and the people I listen and just be
proud of you man because there's not a
lot of normal people out there with your
kind of platform and you know it's nice
to see that I hate to be a dick but it
feels nice that somebody doesn't come
from anything so I don't come from
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I had a chance to do
something with their lives and I
appreciate what you do love you bro oh
thanks Tom man I feel like this whole
episode has been me just playing calls
of nothing nice things that people said
I hadn't heard any of these calls yet
that's nice you just say Tom you know I
don't think you would have killed
yourself dude you sell I've always
sounded like a confident person so
honest I don't believe that at all
when you said that I was like well I
don't think that's really true Tom but
you know I'll say this I thought the
other day that you know it is hard for
people that come from tough places to
get out of there and I do feel pretty
fortunate about some of those things you
know you know the most exciting thing
when I was young was like if the
neighbors were gonna burn a bunch of
leaves in her ditch you know
you know the most exciting thing was uh
you know sometimes my brother and I
would wrestle with these dolls my I
don't know who got us these dolls I
think my mom or my grandmother our
grandfather somebody got him and we
would wrestle with those dolls when I
was really little and I remember that my
brother and I spent time I was like one
of the few times we did something
together
when we were children that was fun uh
you know and I didn't like I just I grew
up in a lot of fear and a lot of it was
probably in my head you know but
appreciate you saying some of that you
know you keep your [ __ ] together Tom you
know what I'm saying nobody's out here
nobody's out here losing lives today I'm
doing any of that [ __ ] you keep it
together dude come on now Jesus Christ
what the [ __ ] man but I do feel
sometimes like you know it's tough and I
don't feel like I'm any kind of I just
feel grateful because you know what's
helped me over the years is people
helping me people thinking about me
people telling me that they love me when
I couldn't even hear him and that's
because I don't know if I would always
do that you know some little smartass
kid is running around me and for me to
still sit there and say man I love you
you're gonna be okay
you know I don't know if I would have
done that and people did that for me man
so I'm just a product of uh you know I'm
just struggling product of other
people's kindness dude I'm just an
egomaniac with an inferiority complex
man and I'm just grateful to be here
with you guys today I really um Thunder
this episode was kind of all over the
place and you know and that's and that's
life you know when I made some poor
choices had a sense you know some emails
to work people and I was upset and
and tomorrow I'll have to wake up and
live with that but you know what here's
what I can say I was upset
I don't always handle my upsetting as
well but here were the things that made
me upset do you think there's anything
we can do together to make these things
better and I'm sorry and those people
can accept it or they cannot but I can
learn from it and then the next time the
opportunity comes up to stay in my space
and be [ __ ] broken and be a shark and
a [ __ ] fish tank or to knock it out
of my bed I can I can come over you know
I can come over I can come over to the
bright side man cuz it's always there
[Music]
thank you very much New Jersey for
coming out this weekend I couldn't hi
you know to kind they say dirty jurors I
say damn clean hearted
[Music]
and the people at the club were so nice
and they've been working there for a
long time they're good people and
actually the room was better than half
the rooms I've been to just my attitude
needed that wrench come on Stevie tell
us what's up you're not gonna kill
yourself tom dude [ __ ] tighten up get
out there and be nice dude you got this
New Jersey got me have that Bon Jovi
feeling in my crotch spirits own way
[Music]
never too late zone zone chest st. to
come home
why must we wait
love you guys man be good to yourself
man we got this huh
you hold on for another week I'll hold
on for another week man
so I'm saying [ __ ] all these Muppets
these creeps bro part first brains
second be good to yourself you probably
deserve it thank you guys man thank you